so as you guys already know this ear was
really really bad for GPUs at the
beginning of year we started
cryptocurrency mining boom takeoff and
there not being enough GPUs for us and
in videos not able to keep up with the
Mayan demand later on we said video make
way too many GPUs and not being able to
sell them and having to take back huge
return such as 300,000 GPUs and draw all
of this they're trying to sell their GPS
for outrageously high prices in order to
make a profit finally we saw in the
video release a new RDX series with
technology that no one really asked for
and it was again priced way too high now
we are left in situation where we have
to provide outdated GPUs or overpay for
new GPUs with technology that we will
probably just turn on however there is
one card left
Andrea seems have gone this one right
our nice mid-level GPU without
ray-tracing the GTX 1160 welcome to Hari
Sally's GTX 1160 rumors my father
started to sell it with the video cards
claimed it David her news then he is
going to launch a new card next month in
the mid January this cars going to be a
new artix 2060 and wait for it another
card the GTX 1160 honestly I don't even
know why India's breeze technology onto
2060 biggest of the 2070 and 28 it can't
handle a technology was up to him big
Lawson frame rate I'm not sure how the
2060 could so make sure to stay away
from the Arctic's 2060 fix with that car
you probably won't even be able to use
breakers technology expert view a
Chinese website has also come across
this news very recently this leak could
very well be true however expert view
has heard that this new model will be
called the 1660 TI which is quite odd
what would make a lot more sense the new
1100 series which would be completely
identical to the 20 series except it
won't have ray tracing technology
additionally this said there will not be
a our chicks 2050 and that the 50 will
only reserved for the 11-under Series so
our new 1150 may be coming soon I think
that this is how
through 2060 as well but what can you do
hopefully later in 2019 we will also see
a release of a new 1170 and 1180 which
will fill in the void for enthusiast
gamers who you want higher frame rates
and couldn't care less about race
technology now this whole thing does
make sense because it has been over
three months since their launch of the
original 2080 so it was about time to
release some lower-level cards maybe
even in 1170 in 1180 based on the leaks
we'll probably see a reviewer at CES
next month and a launch a couple of
weeks later overall hopefully this team
GTX 1160 will put an end to GPU cracks
that we faced this year and give us a
solid mid-level GPU for the mid to
hundreds that performs like a gtx 1070
or maybe even a gtx 280 honestly images
should have done this from the very
beginning that our technology simply
isn't ready for ray-tracing yet but
fortunately it does seem like envious
learning from their mistakes listening
to what we want and finally giving us
what we want and hopefully an imminent
feature who lives here new 11th and 70
in London 80 as well but that's pretty
much it so what do you guys think about
this are you guys going to be purchasing
a new GTX 1160 and what do you think
about the RT X 2060 make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do it all my comments I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys likes to
be the mixer drop a like and consider
subscribing if we like see more we go
too just like this one but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys on an
excellent
[Music]